Speaker 1: Let's go to the phones. You can
call in on the Friday show via discord at
David Pakman dot com slash discord. Extremely,
extremely important stuff to do. Why don't we
go first to Jason from Toronto, Canada. Jason,
welcome. What's on your mind today, my friend?
Speaker 2: Hey, David. How are you?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well, thank you.
Speaker 2: I just actually, I have a couple
questions for you. One politics related.
Do you feel that as major news networks are
starting to distance themselves from Trump
in all the legal issues he's currently in, are
we seeing the slow demise of him potentially
in his movement, or do you feel that that's
still a little bit away as far as as seeing
kind of the MAGA movement kind of dwindle down?
Speaker 1: I think we've got a long way to go.
Right now, it's not so much that the TV networks
like Fox News, for example, are stepping away
from Trump, but they're giving themselves other
options. In other words, they're starting to say,
hey, a lot of people seem to like DeSantis.
They're kind of building the escape hatch,
so to speak, but they haven't yet pulled
the eject button, if that makes sense.
That's the analogy, I would say. However,
I think depending on what happens in 20,
in November of 22 in the midterms and depending
on what happens in terms of the indictments in
public opinion around Trump's indictments, if
indeed he gets indicted, then you may start to
see things change. One interesting thing is if
you look at predicted, which is betting markets,
DeSantis is now in the lead as who is expected
to get the 2024 Republican nomination nomination
based on the betting numbers. If those
numbers continue to go against Trump's favor,
you might see an acceleration. But right
now, nobody's really abandoned Trump.
They're just giving themselves other options.
Speaker 2: Yeah, that makes sense. And just
the other question I have for you as a
new father, what are you enjoying most
about your experience? I'd say like the.
Speaker 1: You know, essentially day to
day development and just seeing how things
change so much from day to day. And, you know,
she's able to do new things and attention
span goes up and ability to just like kind
of hang out without flipping out increases.
And it really is. I mean, certainly from
week to week, it gets very different.
Speaker 2: It's awesome. Good to hear.
Speaker 1: All right. Things are getting.
Speaker 2: Better. Yeah, things are good.
The temperature here is certain to drop as fall
comes in, but otherwise, things are all right.
Speaker 1: I mean, I can't I apologize for this
question, but there is no way you can get a good
bagel in Toronto, right? That's a montreal thing.
Speaker 2: I mean, you can get a good bagel in
Toronto. You can. It's less. It's less known.
But yeah, there are a couple of bagel shops
here in the city that are pretty good.
Wow. Montreal's known for it. Yeah. Yeah,
there's some pretty good places here.
Speaker 1: And smoked salmon and
everything's available. Yep. Incredible.
Sure. Incredible. Well, and you guys have the
Internet and running water and everything.
Speaker 2: Oh, yeah, that's. That's. It's
amazing. We just got cars a couple
of months ago. That's awesome.
Speaker 1: Very good. All right, my friend.
Thank you for that call. That was a joke,
by the way. Obviously, we love Toronto. Thank
you. No, no offense there. That's those are
just jokes. Everybody relax. All right. Let's
go to John from Kentucky. John, what's going on?
Speaker 2: Hi there. David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can. It. It quite literally
sounds like you're underwater.
You're not underwater, are you?
Speaker 2: I'm not ready. Oh, boy.
Speaker 1: Did you say
you're not under water right now?
Speaker 2: I'm not under on it right this moment.
Speaker 1: Oh, no, it sounds all it sounds
so much better. What did you just change?
Speaker 2: I just went off of
my car, Bluetooth to my handset.
Speaker 1: Beautifully done. Beautifully
done. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Yeah, I just had a I had a question.
I've been I'm an Uber driver and I talk a lot
of politics in the car, which is a mistake, I
got to say. Yeah, but a question that's kind of
been popping up as a 25 year old leftist is just
I just. What's the point in conservatism for.
Speaker 1: I mean, I'm not going to I can't
answer that for you. That's interesting. So like,
let me see if I can understand the situation.
You drive Uber in Kentucky. Yeah. And so
are most of your passengers right wingers.
Speaker 2: Well, I actually live in Louisville,
Kentucky, so we're a blue dot in a red state. So
I get a good mix of people. So I have a lot of
leftists in the car, I have a lot of liberals,
and then a lot of the people that I get are
Republican. Yeah. And I just simply like one of
the things that I've been saying recently. I don't
know if you've ever watched Adventure Time.
Speaker 1: No, I don't even know what it is.
Speaker 2: Okay. Adventure Time is as a kids show.
It was really, really good, though, because there
was this vampire lady named Marceline. And in one
of the episodes, she's fighting this other guy
who's the vampire king, and they break apart.
And the vampire king is like, Hey, Marceline,
you've lived over a thousand years. What have you
learned? And she says something to the effect of,
you know, everybody keeps making the same
mistakes over and over again. And I guess nobody
lives long enough to see the pattern. Right.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, my thought on that is
as follows. And I don't want to interrupt
the retelling of Adventure Time episodes,
but here's my thought. There's two things going on
with conservatism. One is the idea of let's keep
doing things the way we've done them before just
for the sake of continuing to do them the same way
we've done them before, which for me isn't a very
good argument necessarily. Right. And then also
there is a sort of contrarianism to conservatism
when people typically from the left say, hey,
here's an advancement that we have which
will improve things. There's like a reflexive
contrarianism where it's just like, No, no, no,
no, no, we're not going to do that just because
you want to. We're not going to do it. So I think
that those are two important elements of it.
Speaker 2: Hey, what are we saying? And like, you
know, one of the things I've been saying a lot in
the car is, respectfully, I don't have to have
lived a thousand years to see that the story of
human history has always been conservatives
or their historical contemporaries fighting
against progress. Yeah. And then leftists or their
historical contemporaries dragging them, kicking
and screaming into that progress. So yeah, I just
don't see the yeah, it's just frustrating living
in red state right now. What can I say, John?
Speaker 1: What's the wackiest Uber
driving situation you've experienced?
Speaker 2: Oh, honestly, I had too many
bad. I did have one lady get in the car with the
MAGA hat and the flags and the pins and stuff.
And we're about 2 minutes into the ride and she
just casually says, you know, I just can't stand
the way the media treats true patriot. Right. And
so I kind of give it a second and I'm like, okay,
I'll buy who are true patriots. And she says,
Well, Matt Gaetz, Alex Jones, just to name a
couple. I'm like, Oh, okay. Well, I don't have
to say Alex Jones is full of crap. You know,
he says that in depositions and stuff. But Matt
Gaetz, the guy who's currently under investigation
from the DOJ for child sex trafficking like this,
is the guy who's a true patriot, too. Really?
Speaker 1: Have you ever had
to kick anyone out of the car?
Speaker 2: I have not. But I think that's
mostly because my demeanor in the car is
very much if you don't like it, you can walk.
So I think that more kind of line that keeps
people in line a lot of the times.
Speaker 1: Well, John, I appreciate
the call. Stay safe out there.
Speaker 2: I'll try. Well, thank
you. All right. Congratulations on the new job.
Speaker 1: Thank you. There's John from Kentucky
with some powerful, powerful declarations.
As a reminder, if you want the opportunity
to get on to chat with me and you are currently
in the discord waiting lobby, your nickname must
be. Name and where you're calling from.
It doesn't even have to be real. Like,
I don't know where you really are, but it has
to be in that format. So people who just have
like single word nicknames and stuff like that,
you're not going to get called on just as a heads
up. So everybody knows and is on the same page.
Let's go to Alex from Seattle. Alex, welcome.
Speaker 2: Morning, David. I wanted to
ask you about a book written by a guest
you had on a few months ago, Bobby Zarian.
It was called The Romance of Reality. Yeah.
Did you did you read the book?
Speaker 1: I read part of it.
Yeah. For that one I read like I often do.
Introduction Table of Contents. First chapter,
last chapter. And some stuff in between.
Speaker 2: Okay. Interesting. I found it to
be one. First, I wanted to thank you for having
that guest on and having that book I have in the
process of reading it, and I am reading it slowly
because it's a very dense book. I'm sure if you
read a couple of chapters you probably like,
it's very much explaining each piece as it goes,
building its case for, you know, a, you
know why, why, why do it exist? What
is life for? I just wanted to know if you
knew if in the brief parts that you read,
if there was anything you found to be either
disagreeable or if it changed anything about
how you thought about concepts like free will
determinism because it goes into a lot of that.
Speaker 1: No, I mean, you know, when I read so
much that it's rare at this point that I read
something and it completely upends my view, it's
just sort of like it now averages in to my views
overall and just like can slightly tweak things.
So I don't know that I can say that there was any
kind of like Big 180 that I did as a result of the
parts of the book that I read. But it certainly
presented and so did the interview. You know,
I think my view tends to be there is really no
one source that describes reality as far as I'm
concerned. What I'm looking for are thoughtful
ideas to integrate into my understanding. So no,
I can't say I had any real one arrows. Okay. Did
you I mean, is there something you read in
the book that made you say, wow, I would.
Speaker 2: Yeah. I mean, I prior to reading the
book, I mean, I, I really kind of believed in the
concept of determinism. It seemed to make the most
sense to me. You know, ball rolling downhill add
more complexity, you know, start to finish. I feel
like that kind of worked in especially with like
more progressive politics. You can use that lens
and you can look at the way people's lives exist
and the problems they run into. And you can use
that. And the way the book presents it is kind of,
you know, it basically takes things like life and
it says instead of it being a thing that just kind
of magically happened and it's like a miracle. It
frames it as like it as an inevitability based on
fundamental laws of science and it continues
to build from there. And so I found that it it
really made me rethink it. I mean, believe in
free will again, if that kind of makes sense,
because it frames it as as, you know, the concept
of free will is the ability to imagine possible
realities and then steer yourself there. And
anyway, I just I find it to be a fascinating
book. I recommend it highly as someone who does
not consider themselves religious. I found it
to be a thing that explained the universe in a
way that kind of gave it a purpose, that kind of
made sense. And I was just I was very surprised
at that because I'm highly skeptical, you know,
similar to your your perspective around a lot of
things. I was surprised at how much I connected
with the book and found it to be interesting.
Speaker 1: Well, I appreciate the feedback,
Alex. Thank you.
Speaker 2: I would love to
have more authors like that on your show.
Speaker 1: We will make it happen.
Speaker 2: All right. All right.
Speaker 1: Thanks, Alex. Take care. Very always
great to hear that. People are getting value from
from the guests on the show. That's fantastic.